[Music]
an actor at the peak of his Fame exits
the glitzy stardom and fame of Hollywood
in exchange for the Salvation of his
soul he is best known for his roles as
Quincy in HBO's Ballers wells jaha in
the drama show The 100 and Cashes Clay
in the biographical film One Night in
Miami we welcome Eli
Gore thank you so much for being here oh
thanks for having me back so we had you
on before but for people who missed it
give us just a synopsis of what happened
well uh we had talked about how I had
grown up and didn't really have a real
relationship or even experience with
religion and how I had come to find out
that God was real that the Bible was
truly the word of God but that
ultimately I was still living a life
that wasn't in alignment with what I
professed to believe and then as I was
getting uh my breakthrough opportunities
in the entertainment industry um I
realized that God's word had a higher
calling and a requirement for me um and
than what you were allowing the world to
do to you exactly and and and I was
pulled at that point between two
different two different junctures yeah
so I wanted to read something from
Socrates uh that really will highlight
where we're going with this program and
Socrates and actors on acting page seven
uh paragraph 8 says in like manner The
Muse first of all inspires men herself
now notice Muse is a person
or a spirit because they are inspired
and possessed they are simply inspired
to utter that which The Muse impels them
for not by art or knowledge do you say
what you say but by
possession and many people don't realize
that this art form involves possession
and Masonic influences let's get into
some of your roles and the experiences
where that was
invoked well I would
say I had heard that from other actors
and I had heard them say you know uh for
instance Denzel when he was doing
Malcolm X I'd heard the the quote from
Spike Lee where he said you know Denzel
was gone it was just Malcolm Malcolm was
speaking through him and he didn't even
need the script anymore he would throw
away the script and it would just be
Malcolm and um you know for me
personally I had done a lot of Meisner
and one of the things with Meisner is
you repeat the same thing you repeat the
same thing that was kind of my process
so Meisner is a method of acting it's
it's called the method actually the
method and uh and and it's a method
where you are saying the words without
trying to put any of your own um will or
interest into them and then eventually
as you start to repeat them enough times
something spontaneous will come out that
is uh seems natural
Supernatural and so that was a process
that I had learned early on to to use as
I was developing my lines and and it's
funny that you said that cuz even now I
had never really thought of it but I
would go through and I would do my Miser
technique as I was prepping my scripts
and it would be like an inspiration you
you'd see a line and all of a sudden I'd
think oh I could say that like that and
it would things just came uh in in
unexpected ways when I would break down
my script and a lot of other actors that
I would talk to say how where do you get
you know how do you see that when you
look at this thing and I'd say
I don't know I just you know invoking a
spirit and and honestly not only did I
not even realize that but I thought all
the success and all of the things that
were happening were blessings from God
from God cuz I'm going to church I'm
reading the Bible and and then I'm
getting these like different ways of
doing things that no one else even
thinks of you know I started preparing
for C's clay four years I have the paper
still to this day four years before I
actually got the role and I I had
believed that I was going to get an
opportunity and I was going to play him
long before the movie even existed so
you were participating in what's known
as manifestation and and and Not only
was I participating in it but the church
was supporting it I won't say which
church I was going to at the time but we
had a group vision board day where
everyone in the church a 7th Day
Adventist Church came in and made vision
boards and everything that was on that
vision board first of all was worldly it
was
materialistic and pretty much everything
on it I was able to get but the problem
was when I got all those things I wasn't
happy right and I remember even the day
that I booked Cash's clay and I had a
picture of me with my head cut out on
cashes Clay's body on this vision board
and as I took it down from the wall
actually it was a little bit before I
booked it something convicted me you
shouldn't have a vision board if you're
a Christian take it down I took it down
I walked outside to the big dumpster at
my apartment building into in Studio
City and I chucked it in and then I
ended up getting the rooll
which I thought was like I was like oh
that was ironic but like I said those
material
accomplishments didn't didn't bless me
in a way that was lasting and in fact if
I could go back and and somehow just get
the message of Truth and give up all of
what I experienced as an actor I would
definitely not have been an actor if I
knowing what I know now and what the the
costs that I've had to pay right that
other people won't know and I won't
share here but things that I've had to
go through that are personal and that I
didn't even necessarily know I was going
through at the time uh you would have
just said give it all back than have any
amount of fame or money or anything else
I'm grateful that he pulled me out when
he did the thing with the vision boards
is that God doesn't need to see your
Visions because he can read your heart
the enemy however he can't read your
mind or your heart he can study you from
the outside and when you give a vision
board you basically show him your heart
and your thoughts and it's a great way
for him to then disillusion you and make
you believe that the things that he's
putting before you are God sent that's
interesting that's very tricky that's
interesting and I know the Bible and the
spirit of Prophecy do say that we should
write out plans but I think that that's
very different it's different when
you're praying for God's Direction and
you're writing out the plans that he has
for you which are going to lead other
people and yourself closer to Jesus not
storing up Treasures exactly as opposed
to just trying to get a car or or a
pretty girlfriend or a f you know big
house or something let's get into your
roles tell me about which ones you took
and why you did them and if you there
was a conflict between you know your
conviction for Christ and what Hollywood
was commanding of you well you know I do
think that God meets you where you're at
and although I was in Hollywood you know
I was reading actually testimonies of
the church Volume 5 this morning and uh
Ellen White was talking about those who
had got converted while they were living
uh with in Nero's Palace Nero being the
Caesar in Rome at that time who was a
terrible you know persecutor of
Christians some of his people in his own
house got converted to Christianity and
you know and they had to maintain their
Christianity in that environment and so
God meets us where we're at and um
ultimately you know the different roles
that I got whether it was the hundred or
whether it was Riverdale or whether it
was uh you know one night in
Miami um there was always an experience
that I would have where God would try to
show me something he would try to teach
me something so like I had talked about
in the part one when I was on the 100
clearly uh a pagan show a show that you
know there's people being crucified on
this show I mean it was it was clearly
anti- god um antithetical to every the
message the message of the show was
completely ungodly nevertheless God
showed me through the experience of
getting the role and then losing the
role and compromising the Sabbath that I
should be keeping the Sabbath and so he
met me where I was knowing that I didn't
know any better and rebuking you and
disciplining you as you decided to take
things into your own hands exactly doing
it mercifully mercifully and letting me
take one step at a time you know okay
now I'm going to teach you about the
Sabbath and now I'm going to teach you
about tithing and now I'm going to teach
you about you know as I'm in the wrong
place at the wrong time he's still
working all things for my good because
he understands that in my heart I'm I
want to know him I'm seeking him I want
to get closer to him I just don't know
any better I'm ignorant praise God and
yeah Praise Jesus and so uh you know I
would say that the the very last
situation that I was in was on uh the
last show that I was on before I left
left which was the peripheral on Amazon
and I remember um walking around the set
and seeing books with Dragons Demons all
these things I I have you know uh in the
script and I still have it now and I can
show you at another time uh in the
script it would talk about highlighting
someone's left eye and and and you know
Masonic symbolism being on the
serpentine River and making sure that we
shoot these things these are things that
you wouldn't see if you watch the show
it's in the description in the script to
provide the spirit in which you're going
to provide the spirit in which you're
executing it exactly and these are
things that this the viewer doesn't
understand when they see it and now I
have family members call me and say oh I
saw you in this and it breaks my heart
because I don't want my family being
exposed to these things and it's and
it's me that was promoting it you know
um but nevertheless and you're
influencing exactly without exactly and
not wanting to lead them astray but so
that's why I do Ministry now to try and
undo so much and also to just try and
help and be a blessing so yeah go ahead
when you're experiencing these Masonic
you know
influences um you're having to deal with
who do I follow right absolutely Christ
or what my director is saying did you
also find that the scripts and the
people who were writing this were they
Christian or where is the force so so
that's what I was going to say almost
one of the first couple of weeks that we
were on set I was brought up to have a
meeting with the uh the heads of the
show and one of the other actors and
it's me um Jonah Nolan who's uh an
executive producer he also did the show
Westworld um and the showrunner I can't
Greg I want to say Pearlman but I can't
remember if that's his last name and uh
and and and Jack who is one of the other
actors and they're all sitting across
from me and it's me and them and out of
the blue Jonah says well you know we
just were talking amongst each other and
we're all Jesuits and it was like you
know i' I've been reading great
controversy and I know that the Jesuits
essentially their agenda was to kind of
undo everything that protestantism has
built right and for him to say that in
that moment we weren't talking about
religion I thought it it give me chills
and and then they all kind of talked
about it and they started talking about
how they were Jesuits and how they you
know things they done when they were
younger and how great it was and and I
got the feeling it was almost like a A
Veiled Threat right cuz they know I'm a
7-Day Adventist cuz I have it in my
script my contract cont I I uh I keep
the Sabbath and things like that and it
got me thinking do they know that I know
that they know you know one of those
moments and uh and so I left and then a
few weeks later we were shooting and it
was a a scene where they had me laid out
on a table and they you know it's a
future Sci-Fi show so they're building
my characters body in the future and uh
and they have the camera right over top
of me and
um my face is facing the camera and they
say okay in this scene we're going to be
building your face and I knew something
impressed me they're going to want to
get me with one eye open just the left
eye so before we go yeah too far yeah we
need to explain to people at home yeah
why this is significant what does the
left eye symbolize so the left eye
within uh Freemasonry uh symbolizes the
third eye the the uh illumination of
your mind's eye the secret knowledge the
secret knowledge exactly and so when you
look on a dollar bill for instance
you'll see the pyramid with the eye in
the at the very top of the pyramid and
it's separated from the rest of the
pyramid which means that it has been
ascended it's uh that that that mindset
is the mindset of God essentially and it
comes from ancient times like Egypt
where they have Isis and
Osiris and they worshiped the idea of uh
humanistic knowledge being able to raise
you to a level where you can be like God
we see that today in artificial
technology artificial intelligent
technology where they say you know uh
it's eventually going to be like a
digital god um we see that in the
Gnostic uh religion of the of the 15 16
uh 14th centuries mythicism mythicism
all these ideas that a man a sinful man
can become like God and they even teach
that Jesus Christ was not originally God
and man that he became God through his
own works and this is what Satan says
that by works you can receive your own
salvation instead of salvation by faith
and and so uh that
ideology has been uh promoted by the
Catholic Church through these
institutions like Freemasonry Illuminati
and Hollywood Hollywood and it's and it
I was going to say it's uh ubiquitous
throughout the entertainment industry
and so I'm on this table and I know
people that are Freemason I know people
that have joined these groups because it
helps promote their careers their agenda
and their agenda and they want to be you
know successful and so uh I'm on this
table and um I'm looking up and I'm like
oh they're going to want me to show my
left eye and if I do that then everyone
who watches the show afterwards is going
to think Eli is a part of that agenda he
right he's he's corrupted or he you know
Allegiance yeah exactly he's in that
he's in with those guys and so I don't
want to do it and so I'm thinking okay
well what do is I'll close my eyes that
way if they cut off half my face it'll
just be a closed eye and logically it
made sense because I said to the
director well well first of all he said
Eli open your eyes and I said no and I
was like I don't want to and he's like
well we need to see your eyes and I said
well no it doesn't make sense because
you're making my body how would you make
my eyelids if my eyes are open and so
I'm I'm trying to ration trying to stay
one step ah yeah trying to debate with
the devil essentially not that he's the
devil but the devil's agenda
and um and he said okay and then they
talked amongst the producers I can hear
them talking off set just a set like
this you know they're over there in the
back and uh and then he says well well
we still want to see your eyes just in
case there's something goes wrong and we
need to have it for the edit and I'm
like uh uh well I don't want to you know
because continuity and then they said
okay cuz continuity was a scene I'd done
before where my eyes were closed so I
said well I wanted my eyes to still be
closed and then he said okay and then
finally they just said well we just
really want to get it just in case and
then you know he's the director the
executive producers you had to do it and
I said well I didn't have to I could
have said no you know but I would have
been a major confrontation and I didn't
have the courage and I was on the
Devil's Ground so I didn't feel the the
strength of the Holy Spirit to help me
get through that situation I felt weak
and I felt like I don't feel confident
enough to stand up anymore without
feeling like I'm I'm the guy causing
problems trying to do it through your
own power instead of power ex exactly
and and I and I knew in that
moment that that was what was going to
happen but at the same time I I didn't
feel confident enough to come out and
say no you guys are going to use it for
you know Illuminati you know what I mean
sound like that guy so so I said okay so
I opened my eyes the next day we come to
set and they say hey we have a a trailer
for the season we want to show you guys
all the cuts the very last shot of the
of the trailer is me with half my face
showing the left eye and they're
building my face in the in the CGI uh
computer Graphics shot and I said man it
it felt almost exactly like it did the
first time when I had not kept the
Sabbath it was that same feeling of I
knew it and I didn't go with what I knew
was right and the devil got me and so
you know afterwards I tried to make up
for it I emailed them I said guys I
don't want that to be used you know I
told you it didn't make sense for
continuity and da d d d I'm still not
conf enough to tell them I think you
guys are Illuminati but I'm but I'm
making it clear I don't want it and they
write me back and say sure but I know
that they have it yeah I they can do
what they want right because they own it
it's now their intellectual property you
signed your character your image
everything is Theirs to use as they see
fit and so I got an agreement and you
know all those things are fine and good
but it was more just a lesson I learned
from that experience that told me I need
to get out of this business and after
that process I I you know we finished
the season I went home I had gotten a
good portion of my first season money
and I I'd gotten a country home like I
had hoped to but I knew that my big
bonus was coming in the second season so
you had to hold out until the second
season so I was thinking man I really
want to get this second season because
then I can pay off my mortgage I can you
know do so much more and then I'll
retire that's what I was now telling
myself and I was able to have a
conversation with someone with my mother
and then um first I talked with my Momom
and I told her what was going on and she
knows you know F our family you know we
didn't come from uh a large amount of
money and income and and you know that
money could have really made a big
difference in all of our lives but when
I asked her what she thought I should do
and I told her this what I just told you
had happened she said well it sounds to
me like you already know what's going to
happen if you do second season because
if they've already caused you to
compromise that much you know it's only
going to go further so you need to get
out and when she told me that as someone
who wasn't even in the Adventist Church
at that time but just as a mother caring
for her son and seeing that this
industry was corrupt and not thinking
about the money not thinking about
anything else just thinking about her
son that was really impactful to me and
so the next day was Sabbath I went to
church and I was in my car in the
parking lot and I was praying I said God
if you want me to get out you got to
make it clear for me because this is
we're talking millions of dollars and I
need to know because I you know this is
life this could change my life
and uh and I went into church and the
pastor God bless him Dr o uh state line
I love that guy and uh and he he
preached a sermon all on Hollywood and
how people need to not watch Hollywood
not be involved in Hollywood he
mentioned people that I know that he
doesn't know that I know and and what he
was preaching and he said this isn't
even the sermon that God that I was
preaching today but God just put it on
my heart incredible he said someone has
to walk away today because if they don't
walk away today they might never walk
away he said I don't know why I'm
preaching this and I walked in when he
was already preaching in the back so I
don't even think he saw me he said he
didn't even know I was there when I
talked to him afterwards and I I left I
got outside on it was the Sabbath but I
I said I'm going to send this message
now I wrote my retirement message and I
sent it to my agents CU I didn't know if
I'd have the confidence if I waited till
Sunday I said I need to send this
message now and I told them I'm leaving
the business I'm out I'm not doing this
anymore and I retire and and it was
again that feeling of when you do
something that you know God has called
you to do the feeling of relief and that
weight off your shoulders and peace that
pass with all understanding and one last
quick thing I'll say I just recently now
I've been retired for over a year I just
recently found out that the season two
didn't get picked up because of the
strike that just happened with the
unions and they weren't able to hold out
and so two things meant that you would
have gotten paid well it meant that I
wouldn't have gotten that well I
probably still would have gotten a a
portion of it but the point is if I had
been able cuz one of the reasons I also
decided to retire was because I was
under contract to them so people often
say well why didn't you go do something
else or just do Christian stuff I said
well I'm under contract so if I'm going
to act they own you essentially I have
to work with them and so I I was either
retire or work with them and I had other
projects but I had to do my obligation
with them and so what it would have
meant is I would have been free to do
other stuff and I probably like Dr o
said I probably never would have retired
I probably would have kept working
because I would have had been able to
say to God oh I can do my own thing and
make it work for you and so God knows
you know what we need to do in the
moment we need to do it and he knows the
kind of Temptations and the ways that
the devil is going to try and Lead You
astray and and I'm and I'm just really
grateful that I made that decision in
that moment cuz otherwise I'd probably
still be in the business so you your
best role or the one that everyone knows
you for is Cashes Clay let's talk about
that briefly yeah that was a that was a
really interesting like I said in 2016 I
had auditioned for uh a movie called
Gemini man with Ang Lee and at the same
time he was preparing to do a film about
Cash's clay and so I had started uh
preparing for that and I sent in a tape
to him and it went up the chain they
really liked it but I didn't get it and
again these kinds of things I look back
at the time I thought well this is God
now I look back and I don't know but I
know God can work good out of a lot of
situations any situation uh if you're
sincerely trying to reach him and so
Nebuchadnezzar exactly Nebuchadnezzar
and Daniel 3 and all those things and so
I decided okay I'm going to start
preparing to play cast's clay because I
know people always tell me you look like
a young Cash's clay you you remind me of
a young Cashes Clay and I believe that
cases is the kind of person that they're
going to make more than one movie about
him they're always going to be a movie
about him at some point I'm at the right
age I'm going to start preparing and so
I started going everywhere and just
telling boxing coaches hey yeah I got a
movie I'm playing Cash's clay there was
no movie and and they would train me and
I and I'd go to personal trainers and
say yeah I'm playing Cashes Clay I need
to put on weight and you know right now
I'm pretty lean but at that time I got
up to about 230 lbs whatever he was and
uh and and over the course of four years
I was just preparing like I said I had
the vision board and all these things
and and so that process my career is
growing as I'm preparing to play this
and so when I got that role it was like
the Pinnacle it was like I put in the
work it was a lot of self right I did
all these things I I believed I was
going to get it now I actually got it
and it was a huge success and God
blessed me and God gave me this because
he you know how could I know the future
how could I have done this on my own and
so um never mind the fact that in my
personal life I wasn't bearing the
fruits of the spirit like I said I had a
relationship that was going completely
out of you know a terrible Direction um
and I wasn't behaving like a man should
in that situation I had uh personal
problems with my family where I wasn't
you know being honoring my my
responsibilities within the home I was
living a lusious life out in LA and
going to parties and doing all these
things drinking I wasn't drinking but at
the same time I was partaking in a lot
of the social aspects of being in La
clubbing exactly being out and and just
being you know in in in more like uh
premieres and and these types of things
where people are living any of Life the
social life and and it wasn't you know
and I knew that that wasn't Christian
but I go to church on Saturday cleansed
exactly and and and I you know I I read
the Bible and I pray and you know I only
listen to you know Kirk Franklin so it's
not so bad Christian music exact
Christian music and so you know I was
really living a double life at that time
and it was like on Sabbath I'm this guy
and on when I'm not on the Sabbath I'm
this other guy so now you can write your
ticket in Hollywood yeah and what
happened well like so so covid hit and
um it broke up everything it really woke
me up it was like
like you told God I remember when I
first got that that job we talked about
in part one where I met the Adventist
producer uh I remember I'd come back
from a club I was in my condo and I just
remember
thinking I'm not a righteous person I'm
an unrighteous person and I'm going to
get old one day and I'm going to look
back on my life and I'm going to be
ashamed of my life and I remember
talking to God cuz I had Now read the
Bible I knew God was real I was back
from Africa and I said God I want to be
righteous I don't know where I know now
God must have put that on my heart to
say that still small voice but it was
that still Small Voice and I said God I
want to be righteous I don't want to
look at my life I wasn't thinking about
heaven I wasn't thinking about hell I
was just thinking I don't want to get to
a point where I look back and I think my
life was a waste and now jump forward
again now I'm in La I've accomplished
all these things and that same thought
came back to my mind Eli
you're not you are you are saying you're
a Christian you have a professed
Christianity but you're not a Christian
in any real way you are a sinful
Wicked worse you're worse than the
actual people that are out there because
you know you know the word enough to
know that you shouldn't be doing this
you're doing the wrong and you're doing
the wrong but the problem was I didn't
have any power I didn't have power to
stop myself from sinning so the Holy
Spirit convicts you yes you're saved and
now who is Eli what are you doing and so
now I go this so now I go to England I
start shooting on the peripheral and I
start reading like I said Adventist home
and and I start to get power as I'm
believing in the word and as I'm
allowing myself to realize okay this is
true this is this is actually what God
expects this is the standard and you
can't have both I start to get a little
bit of power but I'm still in this in
this industry but as I finish that show
and I go to the country and now I retire
I start to get more power and I start to
be able to say no to things and I had
some other experiences I had you know
Pastor Dr o prayed for me for some
certain things for deliverance and
praise God I got those Deliverance
because God when he knows you're sincere
he'll give you you know the desires of
your heart as long as they're in
alignment with his will but as I made
the steps towards living the life that
God told me to live I got more and more
and more power to have victory over the
sinful behaviors that I had before
we praise God for this testimony many
will be blessed thank you so much for
being here God bless you Mark 8:36 says
for what will it profit a man if he
gains the whole world and loses his own
soul we are called to model Our Lives
after Christ we should not compromise
our character to attain wealth and fame
scripture provides timely reminders on
The Perils of mindless desires riches
and fame we pray that today's program
was helpful in leading leading someone
to
[Music]
[Applause]
Christ
[Music]